la russie ne serait pas responsable de
l'empoisonnement d'alexei navalni c'est
ce qu'a indiqué mercredi déjà le porte
parole du kremlin
après les accusations de l'allemagne qui
a affirmé avoir des preuves sans
équivoque que la vanille a été
empoisonné aux novices choc des
affirmations mensongères selon dimitri
peskov
selon lui l'opposant russe aurait subi
de nombreux tests avant son départ vers
l'allemagne sans qu'aucune substance
toxique ne soit jamais découverte dans
son organisme
je serai prudent en parlant
d'accusations lancées contre la russie
il n'y a pas d'accusation il n'y a
aucune raison pour que de telles
accusations soient formulées et nous
sommes réticents à accepter des
accusations à cet égard quant au fond de
la question
le parquet général russe a envoyé une
demande des du bisse hier à berlin
elle a été reçue par la partie allemande
il n'y a pas encore eu de réponse hier
lors d'une conversation ministère des
affaires étrangères notre ambassadeur à
berlin n'a pas non plus reçu
d'informations spécifiques sur les
résultats des recherches menées par les
spécialistes allemands qui leur ont
permis de conclure un empoisonnement la
veille
angela merkel n'avait pas hésité à
qualifier la vanille comme étant victime
d'un crime
alex et nos valises alexeï navalni est
victime d'un crime
il était censé être réduit au silence et
je le condamne de la manière la plus
vide
possible au nom de l'ensemble du
gouvernement allemand nous attendons du
gouvernement russe qu'il s'explique sur
cet incident chen et fiat s'est achevée
il ya maintenant des questions très
sérieuses auxquelles seul le
gouvernement russe peut et doit répondre
lors d'un entretien entre le premier
ministre russe michail michou steen et
le président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko
ce dernier a prétendu avoir en sa
possession des preuves et plus
précisément un nombre registre mans
mettant en doute l'accusation des
autorités allemandes la chancelière
allemande a déclaré que certains
voulaient clouer le bec de navalni et
maintenant varsovie parle avec berlin
nous allons tout préparer et envoyer au
fsb
il y a deux interlocuteurs qui disent
clairement qu'il s'agit d'une
falsification
il n'y a eu aucun empoisonnement de
navalni un groupe de spécialistes
d'après ce que je comprends à préparer
des faits pour merkel pour
l'administration allemande et peut-être
également la déclaration qu'elle a
réalisé ils ont agi ainsi pour je cite
apprendre à poutine à ne pas mettre son
nez dans les affaires de la biélorussie
vous voyez à quel point ces gens sont
hypocrites
de son côté l'union européenne appelle
moscou à une enquête et n'exclut pas des
sanctions
une enquête pourtant préalablement
initiée par moscou qui s'est par
ailleurs toujours dit prêt à partager
les analyses des échantillons de son
d'alexei navalni